salut aujourd'hui je suis dans les
langes du grand point virgule avec
françois martinez lui chez moi alors ce
mental boyle est un peu particulier déjà
il est plus court que d'habitude et
surtout je ne fais rien et vous savez
pourquoi
parce que ces mecs là c'est un magicien
en soi c'est un pote abbas dans la plaie
marty on s'est rencontrés je crois au
pmc 2010 bon ça se suit ce don qui sera
pas là moi je l' ai vu beaucoup plus
longtemps avant hier faire une
conférence en bretagne sur le mental
c'est vrai à lorient lors il était un
gros barbu qui m'avait mais on s'est
vraiment rencontré effectivement en 2010
tu vois là j'apprends vraiment un truc
en fait pour moi ouais c'était dans les
loges d'un pnc des rencontres en
logements d'après moi pour la première
fois et surtout une galère de
présentation de ce spectacle
ouais on a été obligé de présenter à
larache ah oui cool car si on a tous les
crises dix minutes avant de monter sur
tes écrits ouais voilà puisqu'on prend
on a on a eu des programmes et c'est
assez rigolo puisqu'à la fin de ce
spectacle ont été cassés et qu'on se
connaissait depuis des années voilà et
du coup c'était vrai d'où la fameuse
aujourd'hui il est pur du tout en
bretagne et il est par ailleurs il est à
paris les dimanche lundi mardi pour
l'instant au théâtre des blancs manteaux
c'est moi oh
photoshop et ça c'est cool donc mon kiff
à moi c'est que c'est qu'aujourd'hui
c'est martine qui va faire un petit tour
de magie d'un côté ça correspond qu'à la
côte à toi c'est mon côté breton
tu peux vérifier son taux d'alcoolémie
voir combien tu as le goût sommet grâce
à un simple ballon la deux par contre
jusqu'au jour où ça ça c'est le
déclencheur de l'alcootest est génial il
a juste à faire ça et enfin moi je suis
presque à un litre de consommation
d'alcool
voilà donc qu'un ce sera la marque comme
ça le leem truc de dingue
vous avez vu vous n'avez pas menti c'est
vraiment un truc de dingue
il fait des trucs de tam sur scène à
aller voir son spectacle c'est les
dimanche lundi et mardi au théâtre des
blancs manteaux à paris et si ça se
trouve au moment où tu regarderas cette
vidéo il y aura deux dates donc le plus
simple c'est que tu suives le descriptif
que je mets dans le lien merci beaucoup
m'ont d'ailleurs bravo à toi c'est moi
qui a traversé et quand elles ont
rendez-vous à demain 17h pour le
prochain mentale blog ciao